the family moves into a house and demons
wanna [ __ ] on them yep we've seen the
premise before here's my review of the
conjuring the conjuring another movie
from director James Wan the director of
insidious the director saw the director
of death sentence the movie with Kevin
Bacon Kevin Bacon good actor I think
he's a homosexual anyway back to the
conjuring this film is a horror film how
is its horror tell you what guys it is
creepy it is scary at times it is Tara
[ __ ] fine I literally [ __ ] my pants
AMC Berbick 16 had to clean up a pile of
poop after what I did here's what I will
say though it's not as scary as everyone
else was making not to be it's one of a
thriller you know it's got a lot of fun
to it but it's not like the scariest
thing in the planet you know regardless
of the [ __ ] on the AMC Berbick 16
seat the directing of this is really
good in the cinematography absolutely
excellent look how they kinda it's like
a throwback live like they shoot it's
sort of like how in 1970s movie would
have needed the zoom ins and stuff like
that there's the whole imagery overall
you know it's great production design it
looks a lot like the movie deep throat
you know the fact that it's based on a
true story makes it ten times scarier
even though you know something tropical
like this [ __ ] I still believe it can
happen now take some people are saying
oh it's not that original well no it's
not supposed to be the most original
thing on the planet it's supposed to be
like an demolish the things it supposed
to be like a throwback vibe I like it
because the movie builds tension it's
not like trying to scare you the whole
time it's more like a drama that is also
a horror film at the same time not the
other way around and the leads are great
the war is the paranormal investigators
sorry Patrick Wilson this guy every
movie I see him in he's either naked or
has a shirt off and Sidious you can have
a shirt off and he's in his underwear so
he compensated and this movie he is
fully closed the whole time I was really
hoping this time he could get a look at
his penis but no we did not get it gosh
I like to conjure up that penis and then
Vera Farmiga not verified
véra there Johnny whatever the [ __ ] this
Romans name is she's beautiful to look
at this is a great [ __ ] job in this
role like she's getting creepy look at
the same time you really like her
you really trust her we're like about
these two characters is that they're not
like you know con artists they're not
people who are like Oh ghost them good
we're you're gonna know for sure let's
do this the zoo's right now no they
actually take time to go hey hey hey it
just might be your [ __ ] pipes and the
ceiling or something man might not be a
ghost it will only take on cases that
may know for sure has paranormal
activity going on huh I referenced
another movie Paranormal Activity I'll
show you some paranormal activity sounds
dirty doesn't it but what the [ __ ] does
it really mean it means nothing
even that sounded naughty and the whole
supporting cast is great too they got
wrong Livingston is back Ron Livingston
who you might have seen in office space
and nothing else probably he is in this
movie after 12 [ __ ] years or however
long ago office space came out two
decades ago he does a really good job
but I like about in one pointing him out
is because he's not a stupid dad like
how most horror movies are you actually
you know he's reasonable and this woman
whose name I still have not looked up
for some reason who plays the mother
does a really good job she's a woman at
the trailer gets terrified by the whole
clam enhancing some of the best scary
moments are actually when they're with
her I don't wanna give it away but man
no it's uh it's pretty scary shoes and
the score to the score
Fantastico what I love about this movie
though is it's not filled with music
that are out there let's silent moments
throughout even the scariest moments
don't have any music it's not one of
those movies there's cheap scares they
just blast music in your face and it
gets annoying because it's a cheap jump
scare really there's some flaws with the
film sure but not really for the most
part it's just a damn good film it's
better than almost horror films I've
seen it's not just a horror film it's
just a really good film in general get
it comedy I was being in general let me
get straight to the point here oh no I
gotta see the conjuring got it super
right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for the conjuring why don't you
go ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me tell me your top three
favorite horror movie says I know my
Astro number one your there's gonna be
food you remember one just tell me your
top three favorites anybody go ahead and
follow me on Twitter you can click the
link right here you better click this
link or else
a demon's gonna come get you just pick
up the comedy doesn't stop and if you
want to see a more in-depth review of
the conjuring go ahead and check out my
show called reasons a seat
where we have a special guest star
Michelle Q on the show that's right
she's pretty she's Hispanic one time she
called me a racist she's wrong I'm not
racist that's why I'm attracted her
that's why I do things sexually to her
that's why I never see things like this
to her in person because this could be
considered sexual harassment that's why
she doesn't watch this show hey Michelle
how do boobs last but not least if you
want to get updated every time one of my
reviews is up go ahead and click on this
buddy to subscribe
haha the penis that's what is that right
there conjure up this bad boy see how
long you can conjure the comedy is
really good today
you